[Music]
I want to tell you about radium a most
peculiar and remarkable element because
it does not behave as it should science
is changing and the very people who are
running signs are the people who believe
the world is flat and I'm going to prove
them wrong
yo Maria Sklodowska I'm Curie your
science is brilliant you're proposing a
partnership that's exactly what I'm
doing
you're just extraordinary
there is another element of skewing the
results you think you found an
undiscovered element you have
fundamentally misunderstood the atom our
works been nominated for the Nobel Prize
for our discovery of radioactivity and
the commendation only mentions my name
I'm just the worst isn't that right what
have they ever treated I am the wife of
Pierre Curie I want to protest in the
strongest possible terms it is a
distinct lack of respect they don't like
you will have other people's opinions
ever affected anything after due to the
extraordinary you change the world
[Music]
who those that say that radium is making
him sick he's invented a poison
the things that make us weak to the
things that make us strong
while science could cure cancer
this is my lighter
and I will win it
[Applause]
[Music]